[Music]
i'm jesper sorenson and i'm a professor
of organizational behavior at the
stanford graduate school of business i
teach a course called crafting and
leading strategy here are five key
takeaways from that course
we often think of strategists as people
who articulate grand visions draw up a
blueprint and then tell their teams to
make it happen that's wrong a strategy
is a continually evolving course of
action not a monument to your genius
the difference between architecture and
strategy is that while the ground
underneath a building rarely changes in
unforeseen ways everything in your world
is subject to change and that means that
you cannot simply do a bunch of analysis
come up with an answer and then give
people marching orders and wait to see
the results
you need to think about your strategy
every day
it is not a set it and forget it kind of
thing
[Music]
executives around the world lack
confidence in their company's strategies
and in their own strategy skills
one big reason for this is that they
equate strategy with planning
they believe that doing strategy
requires uniquely rare expertise and
insights but as glenn carroll and i
argue in our book making great strategy
the core of any sustainably successful
strategy is a logically coherent
argument a story about how actions and
investments lead to success
we all engage in this kind of reasoning
in our daily lives but too often when it
comes to strategy we forget to apply our
reasoning skills in a disciplined way
nobody knows your organization and your
market better than you
all that stands between you and a great
strategy
is a disciplined reasoning that surfaces
the most critical drivers of success
some years ago i interviewed executives
at a large silicon valley company to
understand the challenges they were
facing with strategy and execution one
executive said to me the problem is that
we talk about the what not the why
in other words company leaders would
issue a to-do list of sorts grow market
share by 5
cut costs by 10
invest more resources and marketing etc
but they were never clearly told how
these things fit together what the
underlying logic of action was supposed
to be
as a leader with a coherent strategy you
have a method to your madness
your strategy is your unique way of
connecting the dots
but if you only give people a to-do list
you force them to connect the dots on
their own making it much more likely
that they will do something you do not
want
instead whenever you ask someone to
accomplish a specific objective always
help them see how it fits into the
bigger story how it fits in the logic of
your strategy
as strategic leaders we continually
strive to improve our strategy to find
ways to improve our organization's
economic prosperity but how can we best
do this
the starting point is to embrace the
idea that your strategy is your theory
of success or your belief about how
causes lead to effects and how inputs
lead to outputs
but these theories only exist in the
mind how do we know they are true or
worth pursuing
well we can start by recognizing that
every time we act in accordance with our
strategy we are generating evidence
did our decision lead to the
consequences we expected
if they did we can feel more confident
in our strategy and sleep better at
night at least for a while and if they
did not we may need to rethink our
strategy
fundamentally every strategist should
think like a scientist using evidence
and data to improve their understanding
[Music]
i like to ask students how they would
know whether they have a good strategy
they'll debate this for a long time
talking about profit and growth and kpis
but it's a trick question
the truth is you can never really be
sure that your success is due to your
actions as opposed to factors beyond
your control or luck
this messiness and uncertainty
frustrates many people when it comes to
strategy
but here's a different way to think
about it
the uncertainty is the price of
discovery
and greatness our strategy is an
expression of how we think the world
works but we should also embrace the
idea that doing strategy is a learning
process that is an opportunity for us to
understand more about how the world
works
if we can embrace this uncertainty we'll
be in a better position to make the
world a better place
i wrote this book called making great
strategy
which my my adult kids love to make fun
of
um especially the title and so every
time we now try to do something like go
to a restaurant or talk about a problem
in their job or anything like that
they're like well it's because they
didn't make a great strategy and then
they laugh gloriously and so and so
forth and by the way i think only one of
them has read the book so
[Music]
[Music]
you